Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo! BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning, Ruffians!
We're at our 105th episode!
I'm 105th episode!
BAU BAU!
I'm 100 and what?
105th episode!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Before we go, Ruffians, we're already at the end of the week.
Right!
Where did this week go?
I think I know where it went.
I think I know too.
I saw a bunch of maybe new viewers!
Maybe this is your first time watching FUWAMOCO Morning!
Well, to explain for some of those that are joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
And a brand new weekend just about to start!
A weekend full of FUWAMOCO-fans!
A first summer time weekend!
Summer is officially starting!
Well, only happy things, exciting things, good things happen in summer, right Moco-chan?
That's what you probably wish!
Let's see the Pero Sighting show.
De-den!
What is... Is this like a cryptic video?
I don't really like this.
What happened?
This is the video that was found by those Ruffians.
Ruffians!
Do you not realize how dangerous these warehouses are?
Yeah.
Ruffians' peril's always lurking in places like these, you know.
Warehouses, construction sites, bars.
You have to be careful.
Look at all the peril sightings we get from their hunt.
We always get them from here.
You're in his territory.
You have to look out.
He's trying to capture a meal.
Warehouse is a perfect place for that.
Ruffians, you know, if you're going to enter any warehouse or construction sites, you gotta make sure that you bring your pudding with you just in case, okay?
Are you sure not the... the... what's it?
Safety wearer.
Safety wearer is good too, but nothing stops Pero like a pudding does.
Don't forget it, okay?
And pudding.
Okay, safety wear and pleading!
BAU BAU!
Most effective that way.
Most effective, you know.
Ruffians, summertime only starts with happy things.
Except for maybe FUWAMOCO.
Right, Moco-chan?
Yeah.
Ruffians, um, did you notice that maybe earlier this week we were a little bit quiet?
You know?
Yeah.
Well, that's because we were down for three days because we got food poisoning.
BAU BAU.
It's the first time that we've been seriously ill.
You know, other than my barker and migraines every now and then.
You know, since we debuted.
Yeah.
Couldn't come at a worse time.
Yeah, Fuwawa had it the roughest too.
You know, we had some time before dance practice so you know we thought that we'd go to a nice reputable restaurant that we really wanted to visit ever since we got to Japan but we just couldn't because we're really busy and... and Ruffians.
If you're in Japan, you're gonna go to a restaurant.
What are you gonna have to eat?
Yeah.
It was that.
So, uh, we're both really, really out of it for a while.
Yeah.
It took me until yesterday, yesterday night!
A couple hours ago.
Ah, yesterday night, but- No!
I'm, I'm eating.
I'm eating again!
A bit again.
Yummy peach.
But, you know, now, it was really rough, but now, we're back feeling our souls are fluffy and fuzzy souls again, all for you!
Yeah!
And that's great!
You know why?
Cuz we have so much to do now!
You know, it was supposed to be FUWAMOCO Ganbare Week, right?
You know?
And it was FUWAMOCO Ganbare Week because we had a bunch of homework that we had to do.
We'd be juggling with everything else, but now it's gotten even crazier.
Yeah.
You know, we just wanted to spend time with you and get lots of homework done this week, but now... Things are worse.
Please, Ruffians, please continue to cheer for us!
And also, a big, big thank you to Mane-chan for rescheduling everything for us and trying to pick up all the pieces of everything that the sushi destroyed.
It's like a puzzle exploded.
Yeah.
And then you have to rearrange it into a new proper piece.
It's like that.
Yeah.
Thank you!
Thank you, Mane-chan!
We're gonna do our best!
I think you know, the rest of FUWAMOCO Ganbare Week is gonna be a fun one, right?
BAU BAU!
You know, speaking of fun things that happen... Yesterday, at Day 1 of Anime Expo FUWAMOCO, we had a
Daishou Mini Rock n' Roar Party at the hololive booth!
And we sung a bunch of songs together with so many Ruffians!
Did you sing?
Oh my goodness!
So many Ruffians!
Ah, FUWAMOCO, you know, we wanted to sing a bunch of songs!
Ah, but we made sure to sing some classics, as well as fan-favorite like Crazy Frog!
Ah, we really had so much fun!
You know, it meant so much to us to be able to share that moment with you there and hear all your BAU BAUs!
So many BAU BAUs, oh my, oh my goodness.
You know, we actually heard Ruffians.
There were some Ruffians that couldn't even hear us anymore because you were BAU BAUing so loudly!
And that's exactly the spirit, Ruffians!
There were so many Ruffians too.
It got a bit silly as well.
Yeah.
Just a bit.
Thank you, Ruffians, for trying to get to know each other very well and getting nice and close so that as many people as possible could watch.
Yeah!
It seems like it was pretty close to you.
Even closer than we are right now, Moco-chan.
Wow.
You know, we really hope that we can do more Rock n' Rawr Parties like this all around the world one day.
You know, maybe FUWAMOCO, we can have our own solo live.
Maybe.
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO the concert!
Not many Rock n' Rawr Parties.
That doesn't sound great.
FUWAMOCO the concert.
I don't know.
I don't know about that.
What do you think, Ruffians?
FUWAMOCO the concert.
FUWAMOCO the experience!
What about song requests, Ruffians?
That way you know we can get all prepared and advanced.
Crazy frog.
C-c-crazy frog.
Only crazy frog.
No.
No!
But, uh... Ruffians!
We actually have a secret!
Well, you know, Ruffians... FUWAMOCO, we're always watching, right?
Yeah!
So, you know, sometimes we can get a good peek
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It was really nice being able to see Ruffians find all their friends.
Maybe get some sun and hugs from reading.
We are friendly together.
Ruffians in a natural habitat.
I thought the Ruffians could see us.
Kazami!
Hi!
Thank you so much!
It was so much fun at Anime Expo!
And we hope you continue to have more fun because... Well, Anime Expo, you know, Day 1 just finished.
But Day 2 and Day 3 and Day 4 are still upcoming!
And I'm FUWAMOCO!
Actually, we're special guests at Good Smile Company's panel!
You know what, we're sure you've heard it already from us, but we're very excited about it!
It's gonna be happening in the Peachy Hall on Saturday at 2PM.
Please do not miss it, okay?
But you know, we're so honored to be special guests
And we'll be at the panel together with YAGOO-san himself and the founder of Good Smile Company, Takanori Aki!
We're not nervous, right Moco-chan?
Yeah, maybe just a bit nervous.
But you know, we're gonna do our best to make sure that our love for figures comes out at least a bit.
Hopefully in full force, but at least a bit.
But, we're Ruffians attending Anime Expo in person!
Peachy hole!
It seems like it's Moc clearing seats in between panels this year!
Please be advised that you might not get a seat even if you wait in line for the panel early on.
I know it seems silly, but it's just like that, okay?
So you know, if you really, really want to be there, then maybe the best method is to go and enjoy all the programming the room offers.
You know, there's lots of good stuff starting straight from early in the morning.
You know, if you really want to make sure that you have a chair so that you can be there to cheer us on.
Yeah, cause we're gonna need your help.
Not nervous!
No!
And also for Ruffians who maybe can't make it to LA.
That's understandable.
We've also heard that there will be an online livestream for the panel announced at a later date.
So please stay tuned for more information about that and we'll share it with you as soon as we can!
Okay!
Yeah!
So, uh, please give us lots of head pats and bow for us a bunch.
Because we're gonna be very nervous.
But we're gonna be strong, chihuahua dogs.
We'll be nervous, but I'm not gonna show it.
I'll guard the figures really well.
We'll take a really good look at them.
A really good look at them.
Because we're guarding them, right?
All the angles.
That's how it's enjoyed.
Yeah.
That's how you guard a figure.
Taking it out of the box and hearing the... You have to take it out of the box!
Okay.
The sound of the plastic.
And the snouts.
And then, you know, taking the figure out!
And then removing the little piece of plastic, the plastic film from the skirt so that there isn't the smudges.
It's like a, welcome home, you're my family!
Yeah, but we're not doing that, we're just guiding them, right?
We're guiding them.
Yeah, no welcoming to the family yet, no, right?
We really like figures.
Can you smell it?
I can smell it!
I can smell the figures!
What's the reason about it?
You're not buying it deshita!
You are buying it all!
No!
Love!
Yeah!
That is how you enjoy it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Don't say it smells bad.
It smells amazing.
It smells beautiful.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very important part of the figure experience.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
On to different news.
I wanna open some figures now, Moco-chan!
Right, right, right!
Wow.
More exciting news though!
Shiori!
A very silly archiver of Advent.
She's gonna be releasing a brand new cover song!
I know she mentioned it a little bit.
After our collaboration.
ZERO TALKING by Harumaki Gohan
Hi!
She's been busy, huh?
Are we okay?
Is it okay to get spoiled this much, huh?
Actually though, FUWAMOCO, we got a bit of a sneak peek.
Hi!
I think you'll love it just as much as we did!
Yeah!
It was very very Shiori!
Very Shiori!
I can tell why she wanted to sing this song.
Yes!
Yeah.
Very Shiori.
Very Shiori!
So please make sure you check it out, okay?
Alright!
It'll be premiering at the end of our Fruv Game Club!
Like we said.
Yeah.
Don't forget, okay?
BAU BAU!
With so many exciting things, so it's gonna be a really fun weekend, Ruffians!
Yeah!
But FUWAMOCO, we also have some little bit of news too from us!
Not really news.
Update!
You know that this week was, in many ways, FUWAMOCO Ganbare Week.
A little bit more ganbare than I thought.
Yeah, ganbare than other weeks.
But next week, we're going to be taking off next week to be able to focus on homework and some recording.
Just taking it off from streaming.
You know, we feel...
We've been really really going and going and going very hard behind the scenes recently.
Yeah, you know, even today we woke up.
I've been going since 4AM.
You know what, the AX panel, and then the Advent Club, and then we had multiple engagements on our schedule right after that, straight up until prep for FUWAMOCO Morning just now!
That's the usual.
That's how it goes.
But next week, you know, we need to take some time so that we can make sure that we get everything done.
You know, and the flu poisoning that we had, it didn't affect this decision.
We actually decided this a long time ago that, you know, we'd take this week off from streaming to be able to focus on some homework things.
Yeah, by the way, okay, you know, we still have lots and lots of fun stuff planned up, you know, leading up to our one year anniversary!
It's so soon!
It's really, really soon!
Oh my gosh, so soon already!
Sooner than you know it, okay?
Yeah.
Hi?
Thank you, Elizabeth!
I still saw you!
What do you mean, Moco-chan?
Is Elizabeth not a special cool high?
Elizabeth is special, but I don't know why it didn't work.
That was Elizabeth!
Why did it not work high?
Oh my goodness.
Have to fix that.
BAU BAU!
We can still see you.
We see you always.
We care about you.
Nothing is fixed.
Except for Nerissa.
Nerissa!
Hi!
I hope you're all doing amazing!
Yeah, thank you!
The food poisoning is goodbye, so that's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
But we hope that, you know, you'll cheer for us and give us lots of power during the week that we're away from streaming.
But of course, Ruffians, you know us.
We'll still update you on Twitter and the YouTube community page when we can, too.
We're not gonna be away.
We're still gonna be here.
Okay.
We're just gonna be chasing our tails a little bit.
Going a bit boopy.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Speaking of tails.
Moco-chan, who's the Doggie of the Day today?
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Duke!
Look at Duke!
Duke is such a sweetheart!
That's a pile of puppies, huh?
Yeah, and the best one is right in the center there.
In the center with the big smile!
Right!
Duke, you're so cute!
Very, very docile boy.
I can't tell!
I feel like I just pick up his ears and then go...
Hello!
BAU BAU!
Into his ear and he'd be like... Howl took BAU BAU back.
BAU BAU.
Just like that.
That poor dog!
Why?
Can you not see how happy he is?
Ruffians!
Would you be upset if I went up to your ear and went... Hello!
Au revoir!
You would be upset?
I'll remember that then.
Well, I can see that dude loves plushies, but he doesn't.
I think that...
You know what's better than plushies?
It's Duke himself.
He is a big plushie.
Yeah.
And I wanna give him a big hug.
BAU BAU!
Very cute.
So cute.
Okay, well.
Let's stop thinking about Duke and how cute he is.
Let's see Ruffians where have you been going for a walk, huh?
Today I went on a walk of the day.
De-den!
Is this sunset?
Is this sunrise?
That's a good question.
They look different but similar.
You can tell, right?
You know when there's like a beautiful scene and you're like, oh, this is one of the scenes that I can keep to myself.
This is one of those, right?
So thank you for sharing.
I'm glad that you didn't see Pero.
But you saw lots of frogs and fish.
That's nice.
Did you go fishing?
I wanna go fishing.
I really wanna go fishing recently.
I like catching frogs.
Catching frogs?
I wanna go fishing.
Frogs are cute.
And then I wanna cook the fish and not get food poisoning.
Yeah, maybe I'll catch the fish and then Ruffians, you can cook the fish.
Yeah, you can eat it.
Cook it very well.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
And next we have a question.
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hiya, FUWAMOCO!
With the English title that you're going to have with Guzmo soon, I thought this was a little relevant, but is there a character that each of you would love to see become a figure someday?
Each of us is difficult.
Yeah.
Ah, if we say it together Moco-chan, it's not difficult.
2, 1, Multi!
Don't chew hard.
It's a mix of multi.
Yeah!
Our favorite male robot.
And you know, recently there's been a lot more new figures coming out of like, older characters.
You know, like Saiyan, Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Puppa Pupp
Maybe I imagined it.
It sounds like it's possible.
Yeah, anything's possible, so multi!
I'm waiting.
Multi seems like an obvious choice.
Right.
Yeah.
Always waiting for multi.
And even, you know, two different Kaleidoscores.
Yes, I saw, I saw.
Yeah.
But recently, recently has been within
The last ten years may be.
Well man, another character in 2Heart got a new figure come out.
That's cool.
Multi?
What about multi?
I was expecting multi and then multi.
So... I'm waiting.
Ten years is reason for 2Heart, okay?
Multi anything?
Please?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Maid robots are good, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Duke was especially cute, but maybe, you know, I have a doggy of a day that's even cuter than Duke!
Maybe you have a question that's been burning inside you since I even asked, but you weren't able to ask.
You know, maybe you saw a lake that's even more beautiful.
Please send us your submissions with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Especially if, you know, maybe you spot Pero, but, you know, you're able to stop something horrible happening with a pudding or something.
I'd like to see that.
That would be great.
You know, your information.
Yeah.
We're always waiting!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream,
We have... De-den!
Crab Game!
We're gonna be playing Crab Game for the very first time all together with a bunch of our old I.N.
Senpai and Kouha!
Elizabeth will be there too!
Down on GGS's YouTube!
Can't see her, but she's there.
I'm in the way.
Yeah, I'm more excited to play a game all together with everybody.
Two POVs!
I didn't know you could do that, so probably not.
But we're gonna have a bunch of fun getting to know everybody!
Do we know what crowd game is?
No.
Are you a crab in it?
I know that we're gonna have a bunch of fun.
We're gonna have fun!
Yeah.
No crabs.
Oh, too bad.
That's a weird name then, huh?
Yeah.
Please join us, okay?
Our first collab with our...
Kouhai.
And our senpai!
Yeah, all together!
And our advent buddies.
Our doggy.
BAU BAU!
And let's take a peek at our schedule!
Oh, this is the wrong schedule.
Moco-chan.
Wait a second, wait a second!
That's not our schedule, Moco-chan.
That's confused for a moment.
Deshita!
After that, we're gonna be playing Minecraft!
I love how FUWAMOCO's off to another homework day.
I feel like after another homework day, after another homework day.
Today, I am concerned.
I feel like we're trying to improve at Minecraft, but maybe our progress is a bit slow.
Let's hurry it up with the progress, okay, Moco-chan?
Okay, Moco-chan!
We're recording!
Yeah!
We're not forgetting it, I remember it.
Redstone.
Iron Ore.
I couldn't do it, Ruffians, this time for sure!
And if you don't, it's your fault.
I even have a guide up on one of my screens and Biboo asked about it.
Okay?
I'm not forgetting stuff.
We're ready to make progress.
So please join us, okay?
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians who are joining us today through the archive, here is your FUWAMOCO word for the comments.
It's BAU BAU BEAUTY SLEEVE!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Panda Remix!
BAU BAU!
Potato.
Floppy Toucan.
BAU BAU!
Winter Madness.
Figure 5.
BAU BAU!
Kwon.
Wolf Creek.
BAU BAU!
El Dorney.
Yu-Yus.
BAU BAU!
Park Run.
Pudding Run.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!